humans have observed comets for
thousands of years as their orbits have
brought them within visible distance of
Earth appearing throughout historical
records these mysterious lights that
came out of nowhere and disappeared
after a short while we're thought to be
ill omens of war and famine or the wrath
of gods but recent research has revealed
that comets may be even more deeply
connected to humanity and our presence
on earth than any of these mythical
explanations suggested when you think of
our solar system you probably imagine
the nine sorry eight planets orbiting
the Sun
but beyond Neptune far from the heat of
the Sun there is a sparse ring formed by
icy chunks ranging from the size of
marbles to that of small planets and
thousands of times farther at the outer
reaches of the solar system lies a
spherical cloud of small fragments and
gases many of these ancient clumps of
Stardust are leftovers from the
formation of the solar system 4.6
billion years ago while some of the most
distant may even come from a neighboring
system but sometimes the gravity from
passing planets or stars pulls them
toward our Sun beginning a journey that
can take up to millions of years as the
frozen object travels further into the
solar system the Sun grows from a
distance sparked to an inferno melting
the ice for the first time in billions
of years gas and steam eject dust into
space forming a bright surrounding cloud
called a coma
that can grow even larger than the Sun
itself meanwhile the intense stream of
high-energy particles constantly emitted
by the Sun known as the solar wind blows
particles away from the Comets core
forming a trail of debris up to millions
of miles long the ice gas and dust
reflect light glowing brightly a comet
is born now orbiting the Sun along with
the rest of the objects in our solar
system
but as the comet travels through the
solar system the solar wind tears apart
and recombines molecules into various
compounds in some of the compounds that
scientists found first in the rubble
left by a meteorite that disintegrated
above northern Canada and then in
samples collected by a spacecraft from a
passing comet's tail were nothing less
important than amino acids coming
together to form proteins according to
the instructions encoded in DNA these
are the main active components in all
living cells from bacteria to blue
whales
if comets are where these building
blocks of life were first formed then
they are the ultimate source of life on
earth and perhaps some of the other
places they visited as well we know that
planets orbit nearly every star in the
night sky with one-in-five having a
planet similar to earth in size and
temperature if earth-like planets and
the molecules found in DNA are not
anomalies we may be only one example of
what's possible when a planet under the
right conditions is seeded with organic
molecules by a passing comet so rather
than an omen of death the comet that
first brought amino acids to earth could
have been a portent of life a prediction
of a distant future we're creatures made
of Stardust would return to space to
find the mysteries of where they came
from
you